trois fusillades successives qui ont
visé autant de salons de massage dans
l'état de géorgie parmi les huit
victimes
une majorité de femmes d'origine
asiatique il y aurait également au moins
deux blessés
l'oncle de cette jeune femme a été
touchée alors qu'il entrait dans l'un de
ces salons il a été pris en charge à
l'hôpital
j'ai juste pensé qu'on ne sait jamais
quand on est au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment parce que c'était si
soudan et c'était juste comme si
beaucoup de choses se bousculaient dans
ma tête en garde à vue depuis mardi soir
un suspect âgé de 21 ans serait impliqué
dans les trois attaques selon la police
le mobile xénophobe n'a pas été établi
pour le moment il est actuellement en
détention dans le comté de crise je
crois qu'ils ont lancé des recherches
sur lui et l'ont placé en détention
le suspect qui selon nous a commis ses
crimes
aujourd'hui dans le comté de cherokee
est donc en détention dans le comté de
crise selon une étude
l'année dernière aux etats-unis le
nombre de crimes motivés par le racisme
anti asiatique a presque triplé
d'après des militants antiracistes la
rhétorique de l'ancien président donald
trump pourrait alimenter un ressentiment
envers les asiatiques durant la pandémie
donald trump qui appelait souvent le
colis 19 le virus chinois de son côté
face à la recrudescence des actes anti
asiatique
joe biden a pris la parole la semaine
dernière et condamné ces violences